this is your first time working with a
bigger budget and i am curious what did
you learn
that while you were making it working
with a lot more money that you hope to
maybe you take with you to future things
you have more money but on every movie
you never have enough money you're
always pushing things to the seams but i
do feel like
what this world opens up to you is that
you can just hire the greatest craftsmen
the greatest people on your crew the
greatest department heads and
i think it's a constant for us is just
remembering like you're only as good as
the people you surround yourself with
and and we just
are very serious about hiring hiring
excellent people who want to be there
and and and have a good attitude and
like that's something that will continue
i think for the rest of our careers yeah
film film is a
strange and very special art form in
that it's it's an art that's made by a
team
and so you you have to have a team of
artisans that as a director
you are enabling and empowering to do
what they do best and then just setting
that vision and making sure they're all
making the same movie i've spoken to a
lot of directors who have a no [ __ ]
policy yes very simple
very simple and and like it's just
really never worth it
yeah um so channing and sandra are still
convance halls
let's take this thing off the rails come
on steve
sandra and channing are so good together
and they're both so good at physical
comedy and i don't know what was it like
when you're sort of on set with them and
you see how good they are with physical
comedy and self-deprecating humor how
does that sort of you know how do you
lean into that when you're on set i
think that self-deprecation that you're
talking about is part of what's so
special about them
they
they both as as
human beings off camera and then as the
embodiment of their characters on camera
bring that unguarded quality that
humility that will allow themselves to
look like fools
that is is such a special important part
of
making somebody feel not only funny to
watch but it it forges a kind of
connection to them because it humanizes
them so much and it's sandy uh is an
extraordinary dramatic talent but she
she doesn't let that get in the way of
also making herself look silly like
she's perfectly open and willing to to
do that and it's part of what endears
you to her and channing it's the same
thing
two lovable clowns i'm so curious so you
guys this is obviously your first time
working with big stars like this kind of
project what was it like when sandra
told you or when someone told you yeah
by the way we got brad pitt who's going
to be in the movie you know it was all
it was a very surreal process where the
whole time it felt like no this isn't
real because he was the first person we
talked about but we were all like no
we're never going to get brad and um
sandy was like brad's actually leaning
in and we were like what does that mean
there's no way what are you talking
about brad is leaning in like is this a
prank uh and if so it's mean
and um and then it was just like to the
point like the day before he showed up
to set we were still looking at each
other being like
who's gonna play this part cause there's
no way brad pitt's actually coming here
um i mean he showed up and you're just
like oh he's the coolest guy in the
world and totally down to have fun and
be silly and play and like do these
crazy stunts that we planned for him and
it was really like i i think it's gonna
be a couple of years before i can
actually look back and realize the
caliber of the cast that we have in this
movie
yeah because there you
are in sort of a dream state yeah uh
where it's hard to fully process the
reality of what's going on yeah i
definitely want to know what it's like
giving him direction on set and how much
were you second guessing everything you
said you know he makes it really easy
because he's just a really nice guy um
and just down so
we would throw crazy lines at him off
camera and he would just laugh and then
try it and like we'd say what do you
want to say you try something he'd try
some crazy thing like
it really um
it felt like working with like a friend
like he's that easy it was really it was
that you know they say don't meet your
heroes but if it's brad pitt you should
meet him i've heard that i've heard this
from a lot of people about just how cool
he is um i love talking about the
editing process because it's where it
all comes together how did this film
possibly change in the editing room that
maybe you weren't expecting we had an
incredible editor craig alpert um who's
you know
just has this amazing background of
great comedy stuff and he's he's really
good at finding the game of the scene
the joke of the scene and like helping
you you know
bring it to fruition and
honestly like i think that we just
we had the benefit of like too much
which is something that you know
sometimes can actually be really tough
but we just had too much goods funny
stuff because of how much fun we had on
set yeah i would say that that was the
biggest challenge is that
because of
what
channing brings and sandy brings and
brad brings and and daniel and dave vine
and oscar like well patty harrison is
like an assassin she's the funniest
person yes
so every single scene that we're
shooting they're all these fun little
nuggets you just want to hold on to all
of them and yeah
you can't and and so figuring out which
of these can we let go over what best
captures the the essence of what uh the
the talent was bringing that i think
that was the hardest part yeah
before i run out of time with you guys
uh i've been waiting for like a good
masters of the universe movie since i
was like a kid
so are you guys still doing that film
yeah we are and we plan on it being good
yeah exactly
i i have i have high expectations for
the two of you um can you just can you
talk about where you're at in the
scripting process and maybe when you
hope to be in front of cameras
yeah we're we're um there's some stuff
that we can't talk about in terms of the
approach but there's
it's it's all happening it's all moving
in the right direction but in terms of
approach it's like
we just we want to make a master's that
feels the way it did to us when we were
kids where like it's this like
empowerment that you get from it from
the fantasy of it but also like colorful
vibrant fun and irreverent like you
can't have characters like snout spout
and ram man without having some jokes in
there so we just want to make a really
fun masters of the universe film uh do
you think you'll be filming this year
uh i think we'll be filming in 23.
god okay so you're still you're still in
pre-production on that thing yes yeah
and and because we we want to give this
the the scale that it deserves you know
get to have an attorney that's the the
attorney that we've been waiting for
it's it's it's a big one to get up and
running but it's it's going great it's
it's huge and there's a you guys will
all hear some exciting things in the
coming months that are happening with it
um but it's very exciting and and it's
being done right i really can't wait and
i just want to say congrats on this
movie and um i look forward to you know
good luck with everything in the future
thank you it's so nice to meet you
steven